condena asombro e indignación en el
mundo líderes globales rechazaron el
inédito asalto del capitolio de eeuu
desde francia emmanuel macrón envió su
apoyo a los estadounidenses
washington es no tener y lo que pasó en
washington destino es estados unidos
definitivamente creemos en la fortaleza
de nuestras democracias y creemos en la
fortaleza de la democracia
estadounidense ins strings of american
de mapas en alemania angela merkel
responsabilizó a donald trump por crear
una atmósfera que posibilitó los
incidentes y expresó su repudio todos
vimos las inquietantes imágenes del
asalto al congreso de eeuu
esas imágenes me enojaron y también me
entristeció que most una postura
compartida con los mandatarios europeos
el rechazo llegó incluso de aliados
políticos de trump como boris johnson
que reprobó las imágenes vergonzosas o
benjamín netanyahu desde israel
el alboroto en el capitolio fue un acto
vergonzoso y debe ser condenado
enérgicamente no tengo ninguna duda de
que la democracia estadounidense
prevalecerá siempre lo ha hecho
as
rusia o turquía también se sumaron al
repudio y rivales políticos como china
irán o venezuela una condena que no fue
ajena américa latina' con mensajes de
gobernantes como sebastián piñera en
chile alberto fernández en argentina
iván duque en colombia o lenin moreno en
ecuador
[Música]